what was meant to be a protest over the
economy turned into chaos
police in Zimbabwe had banned the
demonstration saying they were expecting
violence alleging some opposition
supporters who were armed a High Court
judge dismissed an application by the
opposition movement for Democratic
Change to overturn the ban opposition
leaders then called off the March but
some of the supporters were defiant
saying they had a democratic right to
demonstrate in a show of force
riot police reminded people what happens
in a country with a history of brutally
silencing voices of dissent Zimbabwe is
not free where are we going as a country
we're suffering
we're hungry we can't afford to send our
children to school but every time the
police disperse the crowds some of them
kept trying to come back some opposition
supporters are refusing to disperse so
riot police are slowly trying to push
them back the aim is to get them out of
the city centre the police fear that if
people allowed to stay in this area they
could be looting and damage to property
meaning Suburbans blame president Emma
Simon and Gaga's government for economic
mismanagement soaring inflation rising
food prices and growing unemployment
they say they want an end to their
misery and to be heard every road
leading into a rally is good policy
stops there are thousands and thousands
of people that are stopping people come
coming from Iran all were asking for was
just in our offer a matching along
Nelson Mandela Avenue Samora Machel
having
Kenneth Kaunda having and present our
petition to Parliament it wasn't going
to last for more than one hour but
regrettably it has been stopped
much of Aurora city centre was unusually
quiet on Friday shops and businesses
were closed many people stayed home
fearing violence president Amos Managua
says fixing the economy will take time
and that Zimbabweans a need to be
patient but it seems for some patience
is running out kara Matassa
al-jazeera her